toujours en france où les salariés de
nokia ont manifesté a annoncé dans
l'essonne
huit cent trente et une pancarte
représentant les employés qui sont
menacés par la suppression d'emplois sur
le site du 91 ont été brandis par les
salariés au total en france entreprises
prévoient de supprimer 1230 la poste les
manifestants espèrent que la direction
reviendra sur sa décision
on attend de la direction qu'elle
réfléchisse et qu'elle voit l'impact des
ces suppressions de postes ne serait ce
que pour leur business pour qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils sont en train de tuer
leur boîte et qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
ont besoin de nous parce que la 5g c'est
en grande partie ici qu'elle a été fait
mais pas uniquement la 5g aussi toute
une partie de ce qu'il fait chez nokia
software mon emploi de gestionnaires de
commandes a été délocalisée
dans des pays à bas coûts et on nous a
même demandé de former nos remplaçantes
on trouve que l'on trouve tout à fait
inacceptables donc on est doublement en
colère on essaye de leur dire que on
travaille bien si ce n'est mieux
mais ils ont décidé quelque chose et on
a l'impression qu'ils vont jamais à
revenir sur la décision
c'est une attaque franche des salariés
français
un certain moment ont été embauchés très
récemment et aujourd'hui on nokia a
décidé les trahir en les licenciant
simplement sans aucune reconnaissance
des efforts accomplis
c'est totalement inacceptable